[Musique]
merci sylvain d'être avec nous en tout
cas ce soir
merci d'être là vous alors vous êtes
l'homme le plus tatoué de france et
depuis quelques mois il ya des parents
qui n'hésitent pas à envoyer des
courriers de menaces à votre hiérarchie
pour vous faire quitter votre poste
aujourd'hui plusieurs parents ont
déclaré ne plus vouloir voir enseigner
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ses
parents je répondais jacques à chaque
fois ce sont des parents d'élèves que je
n'ai pas en classe d'accord les élèves
que j'ai en classe tout se passe très
très bien très rapidement et à la fin de
l'année tout le monde m'a d'or on passe
des super moments ensemble et les
parents me remercie c'est à chaque fois
des parents d'enfants que je croise une
fois ou deux dans la cour de récréation
ou dans le couloir
donc c'est tout le temps des gens qui ne
me connaissent pas qu'ils auraient aimé
venu me voir et qui m'ont jugé que sur
mon apparence d'accord et les les
parents qui sont des élèves qui sont de
classe e n'avait jamais eu de problèmes
pour ne jamais de problème en tout cas
sur mon apparence après y'a des trucs
sur la leur on a plein de questions à
vous poser
bien entendu je voudrais savoir qu'est
ce qui vous dit votre ia c'est vous
arrivez dans mes temps vous arrivez
minge que vous êtes professeur
remplaçant ils vous ont eu quand ils
vous voient arriver ils vous disent paul
et les directeurs d'école alors déjà
dans le primaire les directeurs ne sont
pas les supérieurs ce ne sont que des
collègues donc la hiérarchie c'est
l'inspectrice d'accord et effectivement
elle est du même avis que madame morini
bosc
elle considère qu'il ya un côté inhumain
à ça et c'est pour ça qu'elle ne veut
plus de gens saignants maternelle ah oui
parce qu'elle a elle ne veut plus en
fait recevoir de lettre de plainte et
elle veut juste que ce que tout se passe
bien qu'il me laisse uniquement en
élémentaire afin de prévenir
d'éventuelles plaintes c'est aussi un
métier c'est incroyable parce que c'est
vrai que nous on se pose tous la
question mais dans l à tous ceux qui
nous regardent se dit est-ce que
j'aurais laissé mon enfant aller à
l'école avec avec sylvain mois lorsqu'il
vaquait ce qu'ils disent et autres
professeurs à ce que vous entendez bien
que ce professeur il voit et ce qu'ils
disent oui ils disent rien il veut juste
faire leur travail en fait ils veulent
qu'on les laisse travailler tranquille
et ça c'est déjà mal passés avec un an
et qu'un élève qui vous a dit quelque
chose qui vous ait dénoncé les critiques
que j'ai moi ne sont jamais directes ce
soit chez un malade à qui vous allez
vous triez 1 on a peur de vous mais les
élèves il dit ce qu'il pense que ce soit
gentil ou méchant donc c'est ils vont le
sortir comme ça mais ça ne veut pas dire
que ça va rester et vous leur dites quoi
vous ouais ça tient votre parcours vous
arrivez changeront arriver moi c'est
vraiment des comptes présentés déjà moi
ça fait 12 ans que je suis sur la même
circonscription donc à palaiseau et
villebon ceux qui connaissent donc j'ai
soit eu les grands frères soient les
grandes soeurs soit ils m'ont vu
par mon activité artistique à la
télévision au cinéma ou mais les yeux
ces nouveaux quand même dans votre
démarche c'est un ennui ouais ouais
ouais c'est quand même nouveau et donc
ils vous disent quoi qu'est ce que tu as
fait pourquoi t'as fait ça enfin
peut-être qui vous voit d'ailleurs du
ce2 oui non
allez y vous dise quoi mais rien parce
que ça fait partie d'un tout en fait il
en vint curial et non sincères et
surprendre deux minutes et puis il ya il
ya quelques jours mine de rien il ya une
les enfants d'une maman qui aurait eu
peur de l'apparence de sylvain elle
témoigné dans le parisien il dit il
n'était pas dans la classe de sept de
cet instit
mais ils m'ont dit c'est bizarre c'est
effrayant il fait peur il me parlait
plus de son look de leur propre
maîtresse j'ai moi même été impressionné
en le voyant c'est une mère d'élève qui
a parlé dans le parisien je trouve cela
inapproprié a dit pour des cp ou déçu
c'est comme s'ils s'étaient déguisés
pour halloween
je suis très surprise que l'éducation
nationale laisse faire ça il y a dix ans
refuser l'entrée aux élèves qui
arrivaient à l'école avec les cheveux
bleus si c'est un bon professeur et la
kiné aussi sur la ne change rien pour
moi mais il y en a beaucoup que ça
divise
parce que surtout aujourd'hui les tenues
à l'école enjoy voilà on les voit mais
il ya des fois des thunes trous et des
trucs qu'on dit non tu retourne chez toi
vous qu'est ce que vous répondez vous
aux maires qui disent mine de rien ces
exemples et ses 27 passes et un moment
c'est pas un exemple est-ce que vous
avez des passes cadets on vous dit que
vous n'êtes pas un exemple pour les
autres élèves à je suis un exemple par
mon la façon dont je m'exprime par ma
pédagogie et puis par mon attitude et
c'est ce qui est le plus important après
ma tenue je suis propre insu à 12 par
jour jamais jamais semblé suivre donc
il ya d'autres façons d'être modélisant
que par son aspect et après si on
commence à discriminer au niveau du
tatouage on va faire pareil avec la
couleur de peau avec le handicap avec
plein d'autres facteurs en tout cas
merci sylvain d'abord avec elle
[Applaudissements]
non